is that they're simple pretty simple and
memorable and the other is useful and so
i hope i hope you liked it and on and
nothing too complicated switch to get
through today also a lot of fun besides
i hope so now the the main thing that
that that i'm addressing today is what
do you do if you have lots and lots of
disks it used to be when I you know when
I started learning programming we got a
kind of a jukebox thing which was called
a disk Abra Mac at our computer center
but during my senior year and this was a
this was a great huge thing we should go
chug chug chug and I I I think I broke
the arm actually the first program I
wrote for it I found it was implemented
integer programming Ralph gamma just
invented a new into programming
algorithm i implemented to he said he
told me later he thought it was the
first implementation of it but I so
unfortunately we found out it would have
probably taken about 20 years to uh to
duty the thing we didn't have very much
computer memory in those days and the
diskless was huge far we had half a
megabyte and i saw when i visited the
soviet union in 70s i saw i saw their
disk unit which was which had to be kept
in separate room it was the discs were
really huge massive things even more
massive than the one that's out on the
first floor of gates here which you know
that that libra scope dis Wade how many
times I don't know and and and so he
will give or any massive things and when
we talk about math memory in those days
it was it was not only massive in size
but it mass storage it was uh it was
massive in weight and and and and saw
end and you know how also had that
supposedly a lot of bits on it well no
however you know since the late 80s and
early
things have not only gotten smaller and
smaller and smaller but they have more
and more more and more things on them I
I read a couple weeks ago that IBM
announced another another other
magnitude in density that that they're
going to have in their products in a few
couple year and and it's also cheaper so
now we can you know so now it's not too
uncommon to be thinking of you know 5 10
50 maybe even now several hundred just
in a disc farm which you used to be only
on it only at Fort Meade or someplace
where they had where they had that many
discs now and so I need new algorithms
for this for this phenomenon and pretty
soon it'll be true that people will have
their own chance to use these even even
that people on our desktop will probably
have situation where we have multiple
disks and so and so I wanted to show you
two things the first one I'm going to
talk about is for when you have two
disks and the next one is no I'm sorry
to do this to a to emerging on any
number of years and then the next one is
where are we going to do k-way merging
their large-scale merging on lot to
death now the easiest way to to handle a
lots of disks is that is something I
don't know who first invented this this
this term but it came out in the late
80s it's called disc striking okay how
many people know what disc striking is
just curiosity about half an hour third
ok so just striking and this is this is
just a nice buzz word but also need a
nice idea and it means that you take and
I I like to actually know subcategorized
so the first the simplest thing which is
not one of the two I'm going to mention
is what is the idea of super block
striping and what and what it means is
this if I have
if I have several disks well what should
I I don't even want to have to draw them
as do here you want to see an
illustration from buying three here did
this is that this is the new edition of
my book on searching and sorting which
should should come out in a couple
months and I'm i still got 100 pages to
write but it's me next you know two more
weeks and I'll be ready to work on the
image nothing this is right and do stuff
I'm talking about is from the new
section of about gifts and that's it so
anyway but we only have lots of distant
and what we do is we we imagine that we
have to write the blocks on a disk a0 a1
a2 a3 a4 these are the blocks from 5-8
and we have to put them on a test but
maybe we got maybe we got three disks
and so what we do is we put a 0 a 3 a 6
a-9 and so on on the first guess we call
disk 0 actually the first Missouri is
and then this number one we would put we
can put know these guys and this number
two we do this and so now on and this is
a second and we also range it so that
sort of disk zero risk one we arrange it
so that these are in the same place on
the disk too so just a in the same track
the same cylinder so that whenever we
whenever we have to do some head motion
it's the same on all of an all of them
well then we just considered a 0 a 1 and
a 2 to the super blocks the actual a
zero might be 11 track for 111
revolution of the disc for example
working but tuck basically it's really
one back for one buffer full of
information that we that we that we
wouldn't put up with at it at one time
we give 11 command and it says fill this
buffer with with this block and that's
what a block is here and
and we consider that and we consider 80
a1 and a2 as if there was one super
block and then whenever we want to read
in instead of reading in one block of
time we read in three blocks of time one
from each disk and so it's just as if
it's just as if it was a super block of
sight of that three times the site and
so if you have G disks and B items in a
buffer then then in fact we the super
block has BB items in its buffers and so
we just that increasing the size of our
backers by D but we also speeding up the
our operation by a factor of D because
we can do the three reeds simultaneously
ok so that's very simple and and this
arrangement of the stuff on the disk is
called striking the file and that
basically all we have to do is consider
that we use the same 11 we had ages ages
ago but not we gain effective Dean speed
by if we if we're ready to give up a
factor of compete in in our in our
memory of so well we have a lot of RAM
to these days that there are better
algorithms so I wish we can get the same
speed for less ram and then therefore we
can make you know week we can maybe
reading our larger amounts of stuff by
with one with one eye all Commandant's
in and not have to worry about seek and
things like this so so the idea of the
other new algorithms is to try to do
better than super black striping and and
the first thing I want to show you is
way we can get a factor too with a
really neat idea that was known to
magicians but as far as I know has never
been applied before in in the real world
now but I'm willing to be told
differently so we can't affect your to
meaning that with it you know for
without having to buy extra ram you can
you can do prices you can do as well as
you
could have done with twice as much ram
with the city as far as your disk i
always concerned and up the this applies
to the to general problem where which
occurs when you have two files that were
they were merging together so we have
not only a 0 a 1 a 2 a 3 blocks that we
want to process this is in one file but
then we also have another style b0 b1 b2
b3 and we and we're trying to do
something that that that looks like for
corresponding keys in this employed in
the two files so the two files are are
in order by some kind of a key now said
it was one example of this really what
we're doing a two-way merge but there's
lots of other cases for example we might
be doing a drawing of to a correlation
set oh you might you might have two
queries and I'm going to take the end of
them so you know you're looking up
something in library and you can you say
what but you give your office name and
so you have a big list of all the all
the things by that author and then you
have another thing you give a title and
anyone to find out with the intersection
of the records by that author with a
certain title and the large complicated
queries that we might be doing with Alta
Vista or something like that we have
huge files that you have to that we want
to bring together two files in order but
many data processing applications have a
have a master file on the transaction
flower where we run to run match one
flower to another sir lots of lots of
web cases exist where we have two such
files and we want to do fast aisle on
these on these files not before i give
you the method i want to show you the
trick so this morning i bought a pack of
cards did you got did you know you can
get cards that have stanford
got that feeling zoom up on that though
so we've got you got ties that have
Stanford University on and and i'm going
to show you this trick and I and the
people in the audience before the
lecture here shows someone who is going
to help me with the trick your name was
whole round is that right okay so let me
let me show you the trick and I let's
get you should we get it on camera here
I'm just going to be a lot a bunch of
cards here you can you can you see it on
this train up there yeah okay good okay
what oh I should have cut them actually
but I forgotten I'm too nervous okay now
how about Delia number between one and
ten for 40 okay so i could be for now
you'll notice it just I had no idea how
many is gonna say okay now those wants
me to shuffle so I'm going to shop so
I'm just going to shuffle this way all
right this is part of the trick course
it and I'm watch the shuffle Oh problem
okay there you go I never have done this
before so let's hopefully work now
here's what I want to show you i'm going
to deal out the four top four cards look
at them you notice there's one diamond
one Spade or one heart one club right
okay next for one of each
I shovel them now this is called the
Gilbreth principles invented by a guy
named Norman debrief who was he invented
the case of to suit that are just red
and black it also asks for for this
could of time I'll get a one red one
blue one one black ok but if I take them
so at a time I'm getting I'm getting one
of each ok and the gill briefly he
generalize it to 2n cases and in this
case we think of it as the number of
discs we have is the number of suits and
so this would correspond to four maybe
if I had four discs and I wanted to if I
knew what the next four things I wanted
to read or was I could issue for dis
command simultaneously if they were all
at different discs if there's no
conflict between grades sure no conflict
but if I had to read from 22 from the
diamond just that would take longer ok
all right so so he generalized this
principle sometime in the 60s and I
talked to him on the phone he worked at
rand corporation at the time and never
never published and he said finally in a
magic journal and he says that actually
this gilbert is called the jabra
principle now is uh has been a subject
of far more than a hundred magic tricks
you know looking in a magician
literature and there's a book coming out
in french this year about the guild
building principals own now it's not
really magic it's mathematics although
some people think that there's a
connection I am NOT then I'll explain
your first the trick as you might have
imagined it wouldn't work if I kept
shuffling the cards but i shoveled 1 all
right all right now so here's a there's
another day and the first secret that
you have to know you have take out the
jokers
okay but then then my original debt I
just had the cards in a definite order
in this case let's say diamonds clubs
hearts diamonds clubs hearts diamonds
clubs hearts spades diamonds hearts paid
that has to be that has to be the
sequence that you bet you go along a
diamonds closed all the way through the
same order okay then when I when I when
I started dealing the cards down this
way it doesn't really matter what number
you said I could have stopped after one
or whatever but what's happening is that
that after I've got to the point where
I'm starting to shuffle them I've got
them instead of calling diamonds clubs
heart space let me let me imagine if I
had five suits and I started out 0 1 2 3
4 0 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 Felicity for a 5
suit deck and up and and are then I
would have dealt such some off the top
and so after after I've done the first
part of it they're going to be sitting
there for three to 10 4 3 2 1 0 4 3 2 1
0 until until we get to the end of that
of that deck so after I after I def have
something that's 0 1 2 3 4 01 2012 3
it's going to be at well it might not be
it might be might have started it so
what's actually happened I a deck off of
0 1 2 3 4 0 1 2 3 4 and out 0 1 2 and
then I put down the I put my three let's
see there's this Toby's principle really
wicked not sincerely ok so let's see if
I if I got the so i just clicked the two
on the right these are this is the order
which I've got cards off onto the table
and so on the table I had a zero on the
bottom along then a2 and a3 and a4 and
so when I ended with a 2 and 0 SE at the
bottom of the at the bottom of the deck
on the table is a zero at the bottom of
the deck in my hand to the floor four
three two one zero and so after I
shuffled them I got the the cards at the
bottom of the deck we shuffle I took a
few from this and then I took a few from
here and I took a few from here in a few
from here and great the kind of shuffle
that I did is just call a riffle shuffle
which takes out any number from from the
left and a number from the right then go
back to left and get back to the right
again but everything but all of these
guys stay in the order that they were in
any stay in the order that they were in
ok well now so Rob if we look at the
first five cards that I get out after
the shuffling process there's going to
be care of them from this side and five
minus k from this side so the k might be
0 on two and this might be four and
three but you notice I but none of each
now I'm place nah let's suppose I get to
from the in the next round maybe I get
one from the left and forth from the
other one so there will be a three from
here but this will be the 2104 from the
right okay in the next one there might
be you know 2 from the left three from
the right so that would be the four and
the 0 from here in three two one from
the right okay you with me that no
matter what happens after the shopping
process this thing is still enough in
order that I'm always going to get 1 i'm
going to get the five suits in some some
way so that's the that's the gill breeze
principle now we're going to apply that
to to this disc stripy idea and that so
we got the so we got our file days 0 a 1
a 2 a 3 a 4 which I'm which I'm striking
actually on the disks so I putting a 0
here a1 a2 a3 a4 just like dumb just
like I said before I should this is 5
disqus time instead of three but and and
i but i but I striped the bees on the
same disk
I strike be four are here b3 b2 b1 b0 so
before then benign gloriously soap so
the the bees are I striped in Reverse in
the reverse order so this disc 0 to this
far and that but the bee starts at just
4 and goes to the shingles the other way
8 7 6 5 and so on this BB 10 b 11 okay
now when i'm doing the merging process i
need a small auxiliary file that's going
to tell me how to prefetch it's going to
tell me which fight which five blocks
i'm going to need first now this is the
only slightly tricky thing that you have
to keep in mind and i'm going to say
alpha 0 is the key of the last record in
a zero so a zero contains B records you
know might contain 100 records thousand
records that and they all have keys and
the keys are all in order look at the
very last unit block and I'll call it an
alpha one will be the last block in a 1
and so on and same with the betas these
are this is an old trick called
forecasting that was used in Cape
starting on the first univac way back in
Nam in 1949 1950 by Patti Hubbert's and
invented this and so now by looking at
alpha 0 and beta 0 these are the last
keys in those first two blocks if alpha
0 is less than beta 0 or then I'm going
to need to see black a one before I need
to see block b1 because you can imagine
what I'm actually merging of projects
both I was got are doing this by a
simple minded method where I just put a
0 into one buffer be 0 into another buck
it and I started looking I started
matching records in the you know if you
found two keys that they're equal okay
emerging great if one has smaller key
than the other then then move move ahead
in that file until you get to matching
keys or or you know if you're merging up
output the smaller key whatever the idea
is to go through and and and then of
what we can get to the end of the buffer
that then you have and you have to read
again the one the buffer that's going to
empty first is the one that has the
smaller the smaller last key so by
knowing to be by looking at these at
these last keys which I'm assuming are
going to be sort of spread in a separate
file somewhere and this this is a order
of magnitude less information much less
information so so we can assume that
when these clouds were prepared this
extra information was written out by the
operating system forth so by looking at
these keys I be able to determine the
sequence in which I'm really going to
need those blocks it might be a 40 meter
underneath first but then it might be
that I need a one then I may be a to
then be one and then they 3a4 be too now
the bees are going to start catching up
b4 b5 b6 a quote known you a 6v seven ba
a7 get the idea that would be some order
like it but this is just like shuffling
two parts of the deck together where the
AIDS was what I had my left hand the
visa villa in the right hand and say
well if you look at the first five reads
here that I that I want to do i can
start issuing all i can issue always
five reads simultaneously because look
at a 0 be 0 a 1 a 2 b run these are on
five different disks so mo i can do all
these Reed's simultaneously nope no
content same for the next five the skill
beads principle it's exactly the same as
the card trick that week that so now you
know either either you guys can use this
if you you have a deck of cards and you
want to show
friends or usually if you have a bunch
of disks and you have to cover some some
pockets that emergency power today that
that but but basically if you count how
much space you needed compared to the
superblock strategy you save the factor
2 in this in this interesting questions
honest come on ask a question it's
nothing if not questionable all right so
so one of the things Norman told me on
the phone was that people ask him what
to what to do is if this principle
doesn't work hey chief you know you they
still think it's the only works most of
the time it doesn't it works absolutely
all the time unless you can less you've
got you know you goofed and and you know
one of the disc is down you let the
Joker in or something yeah question back
there we on generalize to k XO apo so
unfortunately this only works for two
input files if you work for any number
of disks you know it so the number just
doesn't matter d disks for any deep so
one of the one of the entry amusing
things of the govies principle is that
you take to two types of cards that are
one is in order of from you know like
ace of the ace of clubs down to King of
Spades or something the other one is in
absolutely the other order and you shut
them together and you look at the top 52
cards and you got a perfect dick and
leather ones perfect thank you okay so
you know the yogic principle works for
any number of suits or anything with you
including 52 or something like it but or
by the way out hold on i give you a
souvenir it turned out that there was
next phase ace of diamonds in back
slappers what quality controllers by the
way these Stanford Kaiser mae hong kong
writing the bees backwards on the disk
no no no no bees have been when they
were striped to the disk you you you are
made sure that one of the files was it
was striking the other order so so you
have to do this over here so you had to
prepare this you know by looking ahead
um no I think I would have always
written my I mean when I went on my
application which is decided how to do
the to leverage you know it's gets its
data from somewhere but the data didn't
come home unless somebody shook me the
disks and you can either you could you
have to the dis Pater was built on a
flight like somebody yeah it has to get
there somehow so well the then we did
the data was generated by some process
and we have process work out the office
in Paris and also did this reverse
striking the best medicine that's a good
point but I repeating that this this sir
that that this might apply to other you
know to other two other things now
besides merger where you want to gain
absolute parallelism that people think
you know you got sort of a positive and
negative rules and and you can make sure
you control the factor to it for part of
your action anyway but something like
this pic that we had for having a stack
go from the bottom of Marion from the
top of memory and go together that
there's a trick you know you don't have
you cannot allocate memory from the
bottom line from the top and then and
then you don't know which which shot of
a coulis is going to be bigger but but
they can share the same memory and that
gotten generalized for three this but it
does for two and so it's all in right
this is the this is the the trade-offs
on you never gave more than factor to
buy this technique because and gain
you're a factor of D unfortunately but
it's still a I think kind of cute
question to me that it's flying around
this pretty why they mean if you go on
this one and the beat them again the
head goes back and forth no no no we
also have to work out that the that
things are on the same cylinder oh yeah
you have to eat young so so we'll have
to take a chance that the bees don't get
too far ahead that's right yeah because
because they're on the same disc but
they are but they are but but died yeah
we got we want it we want to try to keep
them close close by that's desolate
that's another factor right I don't
think I don't think it matters because
they're different discs yeah well it
matters if you have control over with us
if you if you're a standalone operating
system usually protects us from these
little deep be able to control well this
hour but but I think in the future we'll
have a chance to actually not have to
take a random disc teak every time we do
in this guy could almost rates is so
many are that it's tougher to you from
use responded to you it's irrelevant
yeah I know but they are healthy yeah
but the I mean the people who are
winning these these sort competitions
are any in the Sigma duck races have to
have to have control of their discs in
order to in order to do that Anna I
think yeah what anyway we like to have
is you get to have a full track meeting
and things like that in order to in
order to avoid the later time but we
also like to have some way of minimizing
the sea time
and if it's hopeless to minimize antique
car now you don't have to worry about
this detail that's true okay now let me
get to the next technique which I which
is out if I want to cost randomized
striping and are we doing on time okay
good randomized striking in in this case
up this is what this is what i will i
recommend just recommend for a large
order of merge on a large number two
tandem it's again a fairly simple idea
but i want to i want to introduce it
right slowly so i'll give you an example
out of the book here and let's suppose
that that in this example i want to do a
ton doing a quavering well i got the she
can pull this up on this stuff on this
pattern here i have a tries to merge and
they call a b c d e f and g and one of
the orders in which we might need to
process the files might be this a 0 B 0
Caesar these are you first have to read
the first block of every file then maybe
the D is going to exhaust first so we
need be one than e 1 and D 2 e 2 D 3 a 1
and so on and again by just looking at
the last teams in each block of we can
tell if this order it now this order
would call the chronological order on
the following week and we assume that
our that our software would be able to
figure out the chronological order this
is that this small extra information
about the last keys gives an entire
information about prefetching as to
which blocks are going to be needed in
which order and in the rest of my
discussion i'm going to assume that that
we know the future as to what order we
could enhance now in this case I've
striped I strike the blocks on for
example a AJ goes on to disk J modulo d
so but BJ I'm putting on dis j plus one
might be so the b0 is going to go on
this squad and sees they want to
too and so in that way so now let's let
me write these these files on in
chronological order but on the disk that
they are so it's always meet to disc 0
just one two three four a zero is going
to be here be 0 here like a
chronological order on the on move to
the right a little bit f0 is here g0
here h0 if it's here now the next one I
need is d1 then that is sitting down
here on this for then I need a one which
is up here dd2 excuse me look at know
what is cold d 2 is sitting here e 2 is
sitting here d3 up here whoops nope d3
is here um a one with a one is a lunatic
f1 whoops that's on the same disk be one
that's over here g1 same as u 1 a 2 is
going to be on this disk f2 Justice you
can see we're f1 was so I know we're up
to it III ii to was there so III is also
here d 4d for is honest is 2 i'm getting
a lot of congestion on dis number 2 c1
same disk h1 this is not a random
example a h1 is down here so you once
down here too good okay glad you're
watching I I wish I hadn't done that
intentionally but I actually I've been
be to use down here g2 down here a three
lk f3e for to d5 okay those are all
sitting on just three and d 6 is down
here ok now let's suppose that up I had
infinite buffer space in my machine and
that the only resource was that I had
you know I thought so I want to minimize
the disk
this time so at time zero i will read at
time zero i will read it every time i'll
read from every disk so at time zero
i'll be reading a 0 b0 Caesar of these
are easy row and at time 1 i'm going to
read f0 g0h0 dc1 and d1c I'll know that
I you know I can look ahead so i can see
that c1 is it is the guy I'm going to
need before on this 3 before I need each
one for example time to I will read the
third guy from every dip so its third
guy and 0 third guy here is e to third
guy here is b1 the third guy here is
rounding third guy here is d 6 okay so
i'm reading d6 you know before i'm
reading d2 because it happens to be
because it's probably because it's free
the d2 is yeah ok so that's the idea
this would be the minimum time schedule
for this and I've gotten here in the
book i hope i did this i hope i got the
same mom the same thing figured out here
okay so so that's can you zoom up a
little closer on these on this great
great ok even closer more yeah so so ok
now i feel i put ? because that's
somebody up in the future here that so
it's going to be you know i'll know what
that is but i have to read in one of
these future block the point is that by
the time i'm able to look at block t5 at
time nine here you see this this is
there's a lot of congestion on this so
by time of d 9 i have to have read d6
and all of these ? they give you plus 15
guys 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13 14 15
guys from the future after
because of this congestion on you know
this guy d phi wasn't ready until time
nine and still I've got if you look at
this I still sitting here I have a
buffer that has a bunch of stuff from a
three I gotta buff buff early bunch of
stuff from D 2 and C 1 and E 4 + f3 and
g 2 and D 1 so by the time I'm able to
look at d5 I've got to have these 15
buffer full of stuff that got away in
the future there wasn't you know I
needed them in order to in order to keep
this going while waiting for d 5 so I'm
sitting here with 16 plus a plus 5 of
input records in memory before I'm able
to use it well if you work out the worst
case it turns out that with if you're
doing a P way merge and on d disks and
then you need approximately one-half PD
buffers the actual formula it's uh it's
one of these stuff the actual form is
one of these victories for concrete
mathematics it's one of the one of the
things that week that we found the
problems that solved in the in the book
concrete mathematics who the actual
formula of the other number of buffers
that is necessary and sufficient is the
half pd plus 3 halves d plus a half p
plus half the greatest common divisor
with P and D minus 1 and it turns out
that that is that if you have that many
buffers and if you if you strike them so
that the J's file goes on you use here
the ceiling of JD / p you take you know
the first one goes on to well anyway you
take this this this number in this this
sequence goes from 0 up to up to D minus
1 it's a goes from 1 to P and so you put
the first of the first block of each
file in this way then you can make sure
that the bike on the torques of it
that you never need more than about half
PD buffers and the superblock surviving
method would would mean Pete I'm Steve
uppers because you because each each of
your P input records you're using DD
buffers for it for them so so so you can
get by with this method with half as
many buffers but I haven't got a but
there's a better way yet and the better
way number of buffers is P plug is in
the order of P plus D laube buffers to
get almost as good as perfect so this is
what this gives you have to them
absolute best possible time if you have
this many buffers you can make sure that
the disks are always going and any loud
a buffer space because you're guaranteed
to have health because it because of the
striking you're guaranteed that the
worst case can't get worse than that but
there is a better way we only need a lot
fewer buffers of when P and D a large
where you can get almost almost at that
speed within a few percent and that's
the randomized striping technique which
I want to show you is it's also very
simple okay fix my pages back here but
someday you have to buy x + 3 the new
edition you learn how how you do that
now okay so let me give you the same
example the same chronological order for
the AJ emerged but I'm going to come I'm
going to put these files in randomly now
instead of instead of a on this veil be
on disk 1 and C starting on disc 2 and
so on I'm going to randomly of strike
them so i used offsets of x 14 first
files x 24 the second file and i took
pie as an example I you it's my first
idea when I have to give an example with
random numbers i always use digits of
primes b 14 0 1 59 well
are taking mod 5 so offset is zero set
of five instead of nine but that this is
based on pie and and so the same example
we had where I would then put a 0 here
and Biggio there and at the beginning
it's not a win because at the beginning
I have a little more congestion before I
can start the merge I had to edit had to
get that all the way up to the H here
before I cut all eight blocks written
and took me three cycles to read instead
of two but in general these numbers are
chosen at random they're different every
time you run the I mean every time you
you run you have to write a file onto
disk you choose a random number once and
for all for that file and then you skype
cyclically from that point on that's the
whole the whole idea of randomized
striping is that that you use this one
time you for each file you generate the
random offset for it and then and then
the in any proceeding cyclically is a 1
a 2 a 3 and 4 you won't generate random
number for every block just for the Rick
for the starting block and it's going to
turn out that if we do this we have a
very small chance of putting a bad case
the worst case can still be bad can
still be this one half PB young buffers
if you wanted to press full speed that
the probability of getting that case is
so small that this isn't going to happen
so so so this is that the idea of
randomized striping and I want to give
credit that the disappeared in the
journal parallel computing this year and
it's by
that's what's his name I get it first me
borrow this is eddie Grove some people
might have known any Grove accuse a tune
at Berkeley and years ago and Jeff
bitter at Duke University and this is
the and this is of the idea of
randomized striping that date that they
were the first to analyze and I made a
little improvement on their analysis but
not much the main ideas are theirs my
idea was to what was to change the
parameters a little bit in there skiing
when I say Q they took Q equals P and so
all I did was take what what's in their
paper and I generalized it so to realize
that it's more flexible if you have an
extra parameter P and Q which and this
is the Divas of input buffets that we're
going to begin with so so d is the
number of discs p is the order of merge
and q is an extra parameter that says
how many scratch buffers are going to
have and they took q equal to p but it
but you can choose q to be to be for
example d log deer or something like
that anything you can choose to to be 0
but the method depends on are the more
the bigger q is the more buff if you
have and and you can get a little bit
faster speed and so here's the idea is
I'm going to I'm going to illustrate it
with this particular pattern of reading
in a st. chronological order as before
and the idea is that I have three kinds
of buffers and each buffer changes it's
um it's status at different times but
the active reading buffers and there's
always going to be d of those and then
there's active merging buffers from
which I'm getting input and there's p of
these so I'm doing a py merge like a
Tway merge and I got five discs a and so
I at a given time I've got P buses from
which I'm getting input
and d buffers on which input is is
happening right then I can't look at
those buffers the operating system has
control is locked those out but reading
is going on into those buffers during
this cycle and then I've got scratch
buffers and there's d minus 1 plus q I
got at least d minus one scratch buffers
because it's cooking because as soon as
the reading is done I'm going to as soon
as the reading is done by computers fast
enough that one of these merged buffers
is going to have emptied and and and I
and I can immediately use that for the
next read and then I got it gets d minus
one scratch buffers to the earth to keep
the other disk busy so this D is five
then then i got i need these for scratch
buffers because i'm reading from each
disk and at the end of that read one of
those discs what one of my in one of my
input buffers is free and then I'm going
to get for scratch buffers to and I can
start again immediately to read to leave
the next for the next five blocks one on
each kid so so these are and coke use
this parameter that that can start at
zero and go up then I'm going to
consider in my example d is 5p is eight
and q is for appeals for and so this is
eight all together here vandal and I'm
going to to just watch this as time goes
on so time one we are going to be
actively reading a 0 B 0 chi 0 a 0 c 0
meaning from disk 0 i'm reading on
reading this first block and can just go
on reading I'm reading the first block
on each disc okay good and and I'm also
going to write you see we got room here
on the screen I hope so so here I'm
going to say well let's hear it let me
just put in this column the guy that I'm
waiting for waiting for a certain one
and at the first step I'm waiting for a
zero
it means the thing I'm waiting for is
the is the first block in chronological
order that I haven't that hasn't entered
the merge yet so at the beginning i'm
waiting for very first block in
chronological order which was a zero
remember this is the chronological order
this long string here is the
chronological order so i'm waiting for a
zero and up and these merge buffers are
all sitting here empty at the beginning
scratch buffers are all empty now a time
to then i'm going to be waiting for d 0
the reason is you see at the end of the
read a zero is going to be in there and
these are is going to be in there and c
0 is going to be in there but d0 i
wasn't one of the guys that i got it in
every so so i'm waiting so the first guy
in chronological order that hasn't been
read in yet is g0 okay so at time 2 what
are we picking up on the first one we
must be reading f1 on the first disc the
second disc we must be reading g0 the
third disc we must be reading d 10 disc
three you must be reading d2 and here we
must be reading f0 according to our
logical order so on each disc we read we
got this nice prefetching for now so we
know which just to read from at each
time and i'm waiting for d 0 but the one
I'm waiting for is always going to be
one of these that's it's going to be
first on the stairs because everything
previously honest is we've already read
in you always read in the chronological
order which we able to predict from
looking at this extra small files ok so
the active so I at the at this time
actually active merging I don't know why
I put be 0 and C 0 in there
I shouldn't have to I'm sorry I I want
to be systematic so so i'm going to put
put v 0 I'm not going to put into any
act of merging anything after the one I
was waiting for and so these ones either
or later okay now but but I've also got
easy Rho GZ i'm going to explain this
notation in a minute but in my scratch
buffers at time 2 i got this extra
information already had a be 0c 00 g0
which came in at time 1 and i know that
d0 is the first guy that I'm waiting for
and in my act of merging i'm going to
put everything up to the one I was
waiting for before so these are all
called blanket I haven't got very much
active merging working going yet but
then in parentheses is every if people
that are red in that we're after the 1
i'm waiting for now so eng are there but
they follow d the guy that I was waiting
for now now the reason for
distinguishing between his is that Mike
I'm assuming my computer is fast
compared to the disk so I'm assuming
that that although i'm waiting for d 0
i'm going to be i'm going to get to be 0
and c 0 into the act of merging process
before the three is complete so at time
three the a 0 and b 0 and c 0 and d0 are
going to be ready the computer caught up
with this and I was waiting for d 0 and
so as soon as that's done this guy is
active and then in my scratch buffers in
chronological order and sitting with a 0
f 0 g 0 D 1 D 2 and F 1 in chronological
order but now Who am I waiting for the
first time I'm waiting for is h 0 I've
got g0 in here f0 is in here everything
is so h0 is that i am waiting for now so
anybody following h villainous
chronological order has to go in
parenthesis here explain the parenthesis
a little more with that that's my
convention that anything before h0 you
going to be considered it's in the
scratch buffer but it's going to assume
move to the active merge buffer and and
then I'm reading that the next the next
thing so so I'm reading a two on this
one I'm reading on this one I'm reading
HCL on the third disc i'm reading eat
two of b1 wat know the third one g one
what but g 1 i'm reading here end up on
the last disc i'm reading other third
job d three it's a little hard to write
out these charts but the actual logic is
fairly simple and planning gives you a
play-by-play to make it make you see
Weiss really simple some so i'm waiting
on the first guy that I haven't been
able to emerge so now what's going to
happen is during the time this meeting
is going on e these three these three
buffers are going to get over here to
the active merge and 80 is going to snap
into active emerging as well and so
that's going to be absorbed at the next
time easy row f 0 gz i'm actually
getting the whole process initialized
taking a little time and and then who's
going to be the next guy i'm waiting on
what's the first one in chronological
order though i haven't read in yet so
after 80 d 1 is next but I've got him
I've got him in memory II one nope
haven't ready one yet so e1 is the one
I'm going to be waiting on next and and
in my in my buffers in I have d1 d2 e 2
d 3 f 1 g 1 and a 2 from the future and
do you want to Karrde before though got
it be one but the others are occurred
after and now I get to tell you the new
rule and that is where Q comes in I'm
only going to be for the guys in
parentheses only cuties are going to
survive I only have enough room for
q I have to have four let's see one two
three four five six seven there's
actually a blank here but I need for
buffers to start for the disc at time
five so I'm going to have to actually
forget that i read these guys because
i'm going to because do you want to be
clear at the time I tech that time I
have to do the next read in this guy
though still clear but these two but I'm
gonna need for extras q is for us so
it's enough isn't it says that all the
guys in parentheses you can only keep q
of them this is how much you can look
ahead of the guy that you're waiting for
and so q is zero I would have had to
head across these guys out earlier and
and so g 1 and g and what was that g +
a2 i have to read them again so at time
four i actually I actually reread these
guys but then I go on on on the other
discs I go on and move it and move with
progress under this ok so well that is
the go-to time five and then you then
you'll you'll get the idea so it's going
to be e e 1 and B 1 on this one but I'm
rereading the same the same guy in some
cases it turned out with you might you
have to back up and go back and read one
at you not only really one that you just
read but we read one that you had had
read before because all of a sudden you
ran out of buffers it gets surprising
but it can happen and that's exercise 25
ok so now what's it what I've done
however is to the disc going a pretty
much full speed I've only had to back up
I've only had to lose two ticks of the
over / maximum speed in this particular
example and now we'll do time five and
then I'll go on to explain the theory
which the basin theory anyway so now who
am I waiting for after II one
I have all of these guys in in memory
and well it turns out f2 is the one I'll
have caught have d3 i'll have e a 1 F 1
D 1 g 1 a 2 will all be there but f2 has
not occurred yet and so at time five the
the actual lot of details is that I'm
reading d4f th 3e 3g to this is just for
the people who are watching it on
videotape you can check that I did this
right and if there is an error by the
way you can tell me and you if you're
the first to tell me you win 2056 sense
after volume through even before vol 3
comes out you can get just you can get
credit for this error and the next step
would be D to e 2 d 3 a 1 f 1 b 1 g 1 a
2 and nothing in parentheses as it turns
out that at this point all of these guys
and scratch buffers are going to be
usable before I need to get 2 times 6
and right anyway there everything goes
on like this and every once a while you
might have to reread something but but
you know that the possible hangups well
now that the the the theory i'm not
going to give the proof but i want to
explain how they how they do it the
theory says that no matter what
chronological sequence you have the
chances of a bad of a bad case are very
are very low and i can quantify it but
but but but but that's the general idea
of a randomized algorithm that is no
matter which order the secret to there's
a simple kind of randomized algorithms
if this order will random then we would
do okay but there's another cases if
this to order is decided in advance by
the devil but i can still do it with
high quality because i've chosen these
offsets at random and the devil didn't
know what might
of the offsets was going to be this is
you take us on faith but the universe is
not deterministic I did not I had free
will to choose these these random
offsets and and so therefore the the
chance of bad case is going to be very
small and the reason is is like this if
we take in any any subset of Q plus two
numbers in the in the chronological
order so that guy in this case six six
consecutive things out of the
chronological order might have been d to
e 28 d 3 a 1 f 1 that's five if I got to
get the next guy be one whatever so so
these are these are some some pattern of
six guys out of this others of others
c'mon Florida and up and I'm going to
prove that that let's see how much
conflict can it be how many how many
discs cycles is it going to take to get
to get through these q plus two things
and the the argument is something like
that this well they I know there that
the d2 and d3 on are on different discs
but the other because they both happen
to be in the D file and I did this
striking but they this but they to be
the E&F they came from they came from
different file so now the actual disks
in which these things appear are sort of
a random and imagine that we had a in
probability theory statisticians like
talk about balls in urns and so we think
about we have D earns you know jars and
we throw six balls into these urns
and I'm going to throw in the ball a one
went into a random one of these are
based on its offset so it might have
gone into this disk v1 way into some
discs show that random you know five is
has some way of generating a random
number between 0 and 5 but what's what
this particular said a few plus two
things I'm trying to figure out how much
time they could contribute to the whole
to the entire process and so it might
have gone into a different one my going
in the same one the d2 and d3 they went
into two consecutive ones the first d2
is random but d3 with undetermined by
and the e went into a random one and f12
animal now if you so consider this the
statistical problem you're throwing in
some balls and some number of balls into
a certain number of urns and you you
want to know what's the site how many
are going to be in the fullest earn
their the one that has more boy if all I
balls so here in case where we had two
two balls in this wall ahead cavity
summer and with two balls in but maybe
in the worst case i would have had five
balls in the same earn and that would
have been bad news for this part of the
kana logical order okay but for each
part of the chronological order the
expected number of the expected size of
the fullest urn is going to govern the
be an upper bound on the time I need to
get through this part of the other
process and so so now by by using
statistics of this bird of this author
bazan turns on burns in all of this of
this have a classical occupancy problem
from statistics we can say that it's
very unlikely that we're going to have a
large number of balls in any art and and
so then we get from this we get if we
get the theory and and it turns out that
the actual upper bounds that we get on
the performance of randomized striping
is given by this table i have here which
which I says it's a it's a function of
two parameters and I illustrated for up
2 20 24 discs and I and then the the
parameter you use is our of D and Q plus
2 and this gives the so that if Q is 0
for example this would say one and a
half this is the the amount of time per
person per cycle so what you do is you
use a multiplicative factor on the on
the optimum time you you're never worse
than this like if this says two if this
is a 1.7 here you never more than 1.7
times the absolute minimum time when you
use randomized typing this is an
extremely conservative argument in fact
simulations indicate that you really get
more like one point 0 1 45 or something
like this this is the upper bound that
so far been proved and I expect the
theory will be will be improved in the
future to make to give it give a tighter
upper bound right now this is this is
what we have and time is running short
does what i want to show you just a
couple of things quick before we quit
and one is this balls and earns problem
is kind of there's a a very tantalizing
conjecture which I was not able to prove
accepted to see that it was tantalizing
and so I sent it to a lot of
mathematicians to popularize it here's
that here's an example where I'm saying
suppose we have 10 10 urns and I put in
eight balls at each ball at random so
that's 1 11 11 mean that they are from
different from different files and then
the expected number of balls in the
largest earn if you throw an eight balls
at random into 10 earns is two point
three nine nine on the other hand if you
say that you've got tools buzz or belong
to the same file so that means that
you're going to put them into into
adjacent urns in a cyclic order then
then
expected value drops down and if you
have two two and so on so like this this
number here for 311 means that I have a
I'm getting three things out of one file
and the others from different files here
i'm saying i gained two things out of 12
things are on so this is a problem of
browsing urns that you say you choose a
random number for each of these like
here i'm throwing five accusing five
random numbers but the first round
number i throw in two balls into two
consecutive aronson the second round
number i throw in two then I throw onto
then I throw in one and throw in one and
I say how many balls in the full astern
and it's getting smaller and then it's
dance the reason has to get smaller
because we know that when we're putting
things in a consecutive earns aware with
somehow not putting a minister learn and
so what why should it pile up so I made
a stronger conjecture that is that if if
you if you choose for each file not only
its some it's offset but you also choose
a pattern in which you're going to put
the two balls like you're going to put
in this file you're going to put that
you're going to put them next to each
other in the next 15 you put in that
positions one and then you skip two and
then you put another one and you and you
have a different pattern of to a choice
of patterns oh you know they're going to
be indifferent urns but but the
different pattern each case then it
turned out not to be monotonic it i
found a counter example where you could
actually rigged these patterns in such a
way that it was actually better to put
them in independently instead of instead
of putting them in with some stupid
stupid peso so it remains of the
conjecture that by combining two of
these numbers and placing them by their
some do you lower the expected value
that's an interesting mathematical
problem but the actually I believe that
this theory is is a considerably
less than the actual performance for
example in the case Q equals zero might
mind the ratio that you get according to
the theory this RFD and two turns out to
be d plus 1 over to the number of just
half the number of discs essentially but
i but i could analyze the process
exactly in that case and it turned out
that that the actual number was squit
was proportional to square root of it of
d so so the it was something like square
root of pi d over eight I mean but it
was but the number of Indians of time
you can get through a square root of d
times n blocks look even when you had k
equals zero the smallest case in this
randomized striping while the theory the
upper bound said you needed half of deep
so so if clear that there's a great
difference between the upper bound we
can prove now and the actual performance
even so the upper banda we can prove now
is good enough to show that if you take
something like five de la vie buffers
then you can deal with in five percent
of the of the optimum one point oh five
and then since you know so even even
with our weak theory we know that this
method is asymptotically very good and
and in fact is if you get a simulation
so I look look extremely good that you
that all you have to do is every tie is
strike the stripe the disk of the back
of your file but choose the starting
file of that random and then go
cyclically from there and that looks
like a very good way to to avoid
conflicts when you're doing highway
immersion okay that's the that's what I
had to say today
any urgent questions we can maybe get
them while the TV cameras still running
yep okay I'm saying for part Irish I
meant a lot of days to but if you if you
are and don't know what the basis then
then you know there is if I take if I
want to get within epsilon if I want my
racial be 1 plus epsilon then I just
have to take some some something like I
don't know if it's 1 over epsilon D
lobby or something like that but it's
but it's something that grossest that if
it's even if you're at a fairly small
multiple of dialogue be we can guarantee
that epsilon is pretty good
engineering-wise it solved in and then
the the actual formulas are our kind of
hairy looking but the actually the
massive wasn't that bad together Sam was
the was a method that uses that that
uses be trees and and and us I mean it's
it's got a different it's a quite a
different policy entirely this is using
fool okay these files are are not
intended I'm considering that I'm
building these merchants these blocks
and packing them fully are not doing
insertions and deletions on the flowers
and as I've been doing it so long I'll
say it's not a comfortable question
if if young okay okay